six of their last 13 Le don't want to get into
a special teams match up with this team Carolina
right at the top in the month of December in
both categories here's Brent Burns who has
five points in his last two games the former Bron
Battalion sends it across a pass for spetch nikov
is cleared by the leaps Andre spetch nikov
number 37 coming off off a hatrick against
Montreal fired in by bunting on that first Power
Play unit for Carolina no David camp tonight for
Toronto on the penalty kill it FR scor and it
is Michael butting returning home and scoring
224 in you try to gang The Zone and outman the
penalty the power play in the corner you can see
the three blue new jerseys but just a little late
reaction was Gregor trying to get to the front and
it's Sebastian AO again just a perfect pass by AO
buting with the quick release and that one slides
through the five hole on Jones and K Arro taking
that draw for the Le but Jordan Stall the veteran
able to Prevail it's played to the Lea line and
here comes Jordan martinook his shot speared Away
by Jones Morgan Riley Quick Pass Matthews on the
move but Jacob slave it on him Matthews able to
ward off the check and get a shot on to jeto
back into Carolina territory Matthews nearly
kicked off that pass n off the boards quickly
back aead to 34 Austin Matthews from distance
and easy garus with an outlet and there's bruzi
Riley's jumping Morgan Riley to the attack he's
in Riley Club stopped ketov he dropped it and and
now covers as Morgan Riley with the dangerous Dash
oh but it's using your legs to jump to the open
Ice there's the slash into the hands the quick
shot the rebound was there ends up ricocheting
into the quarter booken stick for DOI as it comes
back to the line that shot bouncing through n on
it off the side of the Nets in the calendar gear
for number 16 that will roll through in front
and knocked off the Stick of Matthews Mar thir
spins and then kicked at three to the other side
and bro's on that pass picked off and Marty n
just comes back the other way with keni back to
nichas back to KI oh it's swept off the line by
Matthews and now covered then back the other it's
trickling maybe over the line and then no taken
away off the draw here's fnof coming off E surgery
last March kicked Away by Jones here's Brady Shay
from a sharp angle rebound knocked to the line
and then it's AO with a shot deflected over the
last little while especially with mccave as a
part just his 20th game 54 hits here's marar
off his gate a backand stopped by ketov that
blocked as it bounced up pesi a re for it good
work by Ben to get back and now tarz to the
attack here's tarz Hot Shot off the shoulder
and 88 up b m fans react the officials do not
and a loose puck in front CI just missed and
then they he moved but then lost it Matthews
intercepts it th oh it's off the crossbar it
deflected off slaven and nearly went in the
front of the net here's Marner keeps it alive
again and this has been between Marner and
Matthews so often the Puck's just been out
of reach for a SP and here's the turnaround
and there's the quick oh reaching back and
looked like his left leg whether you say ankle
or knee watch as he sees this one in the air
at the last second and his left leg is caught
underneath and that reaction fairly immediate
slav even tried to get down and block the pass
he actually did get a piece of it but that goes
off the bar ketov able to grab it but around two
and A2 minutes in the opening period it comes to
the line and steered out there by Bunting
and St by sharp is in and a stop there by
Jones in Carolina's power Place click tonight
it has been hot now seventh in the leag v to
got back in in front scores set garage they're
two for two on the power play tonight and that
took 12 seconds wow talk about a determined
group you saw the look of sheld and ke didn't
like the call Carolina special teams has just
been on fire and this is kind of a nothing play
from the neutral zone a two onone though that
they lose part position I don't think Brody
is one that got caught sort of watching there as
opposed to coming in and getting a setup instead
smetch nikov attacks what a saucer pass and
that one goes five hole as Jarvis up with the
puck back to benoa his shot knocked down look
go it's Jarvis he's got a break with chance of
Jarvis again in front and a stop there and
Beno at the side of the net chances at the
other end Jarvis with the block now you've got
this two onone and going down on one knee Dolby
makes the initial play but there on the doorstep
Robertson ends up knocking Carolina will make a
change another time where the Carolina Fe have
been able to win those Puck battles there's KN
Lander right on with brzi going to the net and
though he gets a little bit lower here's the
good little drop pass with the opportunity for
the rebound but solve the second year Carolina
goenda percentage in the league tonight does
it here's gordano ahead for Doby now yarn coach
Doby over the line into the slot scor Timothy Len
has his first of the year kanes cleared the park
but then doy got his head up there and the trailer
coming through there's a great catch and release
look at the reaction of the goenda make for L but
he corals this one and gets rid of it quickly Hing
over with the shoulder to give this building some
life and make it into the corner goes the dearis
and now it's Mitch Marner to KN Lander and the f
up it's Sebastian AO home fre and he'll score
another for AO he's been involved in all three
for Carolina tonight and that's 11 points in three
games in four nights for Sebastian AO leadership
of AO and how he just plays so many different
roles for this team it's been the story of the
night though for the offense for the least it's
been a stick in the way defensively by a Carolina
player that time it's a good read by AO he wins
the foot race just tracking the puck as soon as
KNE Lander thinks it's going to get to his stick
instead it's gone back the other way and there's
LS headed to California next week Doby over the
line to yard broken back and here's M with a
shot off Target sent around lilligren the lone
goal scorer got that to the neck goby in front
Robertson what a stopped by ketov and they'll
have to look at this that the glove that made
the save cross the red line what a save though the
acrobatic and here's the overhead you be the judge
bad rebound through the legs from DOI ah can you
see the actual puck in his webbing jammed right
against the side of the net right on the goal line
didn't it what a great play by doy to keep alive
but how about that backhander of course the play
is under review here but a hard backhander that
one move there when the looked like his glander
was offside they got a tag up and that's likely
going to do it as it comes up to the center
and the Carolina Hurricanes have one a 3 to2